hello youtube this is follow pretty by
the way i also put the same question in
my blog follow conduct daily blog card
and using YouTube of course having said
that I think that message is now down
but I suggest not down for good I think
that what is happening now is were
forcing back gratis we lost track not a
week I mean I don't want to generalize
but the system lost track of ethics many
be careful with your neighbor think
twice before you act in South benefit so
at the end of the day the meltdown is
showing that a word without ethics does
not work coming in right and then when
we reach the button will be able to
reconstruct from the ruins of this
system and your system a new system that
is much more open to for the human heart
instead of being totally closed down and
turning all ways around that money my
name we have a wonderful day